you got it with aujourd'hui on se
retrouve dans le quatrième épisode de
huntingdon ces partis patois père jean
victor la suite bordel une personne en
particulier retient toute notre
attention
il a des antécédents intéressant avec la
famille washington il les aurait mis en
garde contre la poursuite de leur
prochaine construction au milieu des
pins de plats coude et disais que cette
terre était sacré pour ses ancêtres est
ce sa demande d'huile sur tout ça ça
donne ça doit être totale history sotchi
[Musique]
mais à part ici
peut-être que je vais aussi savoir te
mettre en valeur
[Musique]
ouais
chapitre 4 loyauté 7h jusqu'à l'aube
oh merde à une maille du coup il veut
partir à la recherche de comment
s'appelle bias voilà djemba voilà
jessica opus hey oh c'est pas vrai elle
s'étend le sous les yeux allez on y va
allons y voit michael ni au niveau
interne athlètes il va tu me montres
ragon c'est dangereux gym le chemin
raccourci faut aller vite fois l'hymne
il faut aller vite plus tard
occulter sa hâte d'écouter tiao bush
avait raison
au carré c'est bon on a réussi à les
fausses notes à bruce campbell merde
merde [ __ ] je suis ok et je supporte
avec sa soupe aux ailerons
olala mais la balle est dangereusement
blessé encore un peu plus maintenant
13 je suis à fond dedans à bord des
larmes et film
car le tour sauté on s'en bat les deux
étapes très vite pas les caresser bon
heureusement dieu le petit voilà parfait
well as tu as gagné 3 minutes mon gars
allez saute au siom c'est bien c'est
bien mike c'est bien je t'aime
suivent le chemin glissade risquaient
eux glissade risquez rien ou quoi ou pas
c'est chaud allez allez laisse toi aller
voilà laisse toi aller bébé ça baru a
pas de problème si le casse pas les
chevilles chez peschier fichier où il
fait chier jusqu'à aller très justement
moi [ __ ] ça se faire me fait chier à
mesa attend mais le mec en 3 où il n'a
pas pu disparaître quoi s'est téléporté
please à l'élève d'alain bernard est
clair un peu avec l'air tout ça j'ai
peur oui oui j'arrive j'arrive mon amour
j'arrive je suis là où es tu qu'est ce
que la caisse qu'à la fin elle est morte
elle bouche à bouche prendra vite tu
prends invite paul invite enfin les
cultures à l'aide
r2
oh bordel
oui c'est quoi pourquoi y regardant la
ja quoi y'a un mec basse et je vous
taper la tête direct c'est quoi ça c'est
quoi c'est quoi j'étais juste parce que
c'est dicale allez allez allez allez
allez ouais on fait le culte deux sens
rue capron les moyens en plat ont sauté
votre même à l'égout
[ __ ] même escaladé à les messins 27,1
san athlètes on s'arrête pas rapides au
monde et ce au cockpit à l'euro aucun
problème si l'on tient à l'ego encore
plus gros les touchez vous plait plus
grosse part [ __ ] ça va graphite
on saute puteaux france
à bien voir papa comédie allez allez
allez allez allez bon mike monte
waouh
c'est bon à le saut au le petit job qui
a mal passé haut la pacha [ __ ] mais
quels athlètes y avait que tu as mais
court mais lui un coup de [ __ ] on s'en
fout de buter à distance olympique balle
de mets toi à 5 heures avec une seule
balle dedans moi c'est au salon ouais
ouais tu mets y avait tué l'habituel
trio anglais
la voilà c'est bien
j'aimerais bien acquis une moto on se
voit pourquoi il ya une moto vous avez
une petite cross
auplata il fait froid ouais tu avais cas
pas faire le cake est on est l'art de
ras tabia pas vouloir pécho jesse quand
elle était encore vivante sont pas des
gars assez quoi c'est pas le lazer
l'aborder dont tu parlais dans le me
précédemment
il ya baic [ __ ] s les parisiens c'est
pas été des montagnes c'était le mec
as oui c'est chris qui s'était fait
assomer du coup avec h et josh aussi
c'était pas assommer avancé de la [ __ ]
survêt et arrière
ashley acheter ou et font mouche tête au
plafond states où le parquet a battu
c'est du sang et bien c'est quoi son
porte-monnaie oui excellent en théorie
crise on voit la porte moi je perds pas
ton [ __ ]
oui oui arrête me stresse pas encore
plus crise
je sais on est dans la merde moi il se
passa je m'enferme dans le chalet je
retrouve pas les autres c'est mort
j'appelle la police
j'aurais immédiatement où j'en vois une
fusée éclairante je sais pas [ __ ] mais
je vais aller chercher seul dans les
bras on va tomber sur des [ __ ] de
zombies connaissait côté du c'est quoi
il des corbeaux quel est le fuck à l'eau
mais mortel pourquoi c'est un clown
comme par hasard c'est un clown c'est
pas parce que nos amis qu'on n'aimait
pas les clowns avec loppsi aaa où ça
allait très bien avec ses ça vous le
savez il ya quoi derrière il ya un truc
à ramasser un totem c'est quoi c'est un
totem je sens aux [ __ ] hey ho [ __ ]
non
super on a vu quelqu'un mourir pendu
voilà j'ai adoré ce moment et là y'a
quoi mais du sang et des messages si
j'ai dit que j'aimais pas ça dans les
tests avec le psy la [ __ ] de kuna j'ai
pas peur des clowns pourtant messieurs
est vraiment glauque quoi et là je me
retournais recrues qui me fait coucou
sens c'est rigolo un rôle apache la
bonne blague pour se rassurer
atleo aux mondiaux on tombe sur une
petite maison bordel mais qu'est ce
qu'elle contient
ces médias glauque séméga glauque rémois
50 c koi attendent autant jeter plus
elle a acheté
c'était quoi ça mais moins fort le bruit
de vos [ __ ] de screamer quoi amiens
c'est quoi au mec c'est quoi le délire
bonjour merci des psychopathes mal cette
expérience comme à castres pour cette
expérience nous aurons besoin de la
coopération de nos deux sujets je suis
un mercenaire mais nous avons besoin
d'un autre participant pour nous aider à
décider quel celui-ci les dames à la vie
locale pour mémo galès mois à venir à
penser sous blair étaient eux le savent
mais c'est moi vous tuer tu veux le
vieux que sur pourquoi ce toi que tu as
choisie qui tu veux sauver
[ __ ] entre acheter jobs alors josh
hill and happy days âme et hln affinités
avec christine et qu'on joue là mais je
vous avoue que les deux soeurs du jazz
sont morts j'aimerais que frère meurt
mais sa source a souligné de neige après
duels ça se trouve c'est lui qui est
complice à connaître mon pâté qui mijote
manigances tout savoir et lui [ __ ] il
doit d'essayer au sauver déjà je sauvais
ashley lui l'amoureux de ashley mais non
mais moi j'ai envie de garder jobs et
ses deux soeurs sont mes [ __ ] pas le
frère allait josh de janvier on garde
josh je me sens bien jazz vraiment
non mais pas avec les deux vont mourir à
sa trouvent les deux vont mourir et je
les aurai juste déçu avant leur mort non
je prenne une erreur c'est parce que je
voulais les jeunes musiciens
[Musique]
non non non on regarde pas ce que je
voulais buts et ashley mais c'est
injuste ne souffre et nick et je me suis
arrivé au kg que je veux faire descendre
allez allez tu vas décent mais bon il
faut sortir d'ici me suffit mais non
mais l'hôte à côté carole alors all
hallow montois partie
alors sans tache allez on y va râler
quoi ump façon ça va mais je voulais
buts et h
je m'en remets pas là comment je me suis
fait avoir j'avais confiance -
azereix
à mater et sa meuf qui retourne sur clis
et htc savez je ne sois pas déçu a été
déploré a été tué et le cloud c'est un
truc de dingue
oui mais oui s'en foutent quoi au
qu'allez-vous juste y aller chercher les
autres
oui voilà oui je préfère hockey
elle j'aime pas emilie j'arrive pas les
mechs pas pourquoi mais je sais le psy
oh [ __ ] ça fait du bien de retrouver à
le cloud il est plus proche que moins
qu'avant avec une scie maintenant comme
par hasard bonjour bonjour
la tension est montée d'un cran n'est ce
pas un peu oui
la nuit se déroule est devant moi
regardez il ya ya ya mes phobies quoi il
ya du sang à gauche une araignée dans un
bocal
ça se passe bien ouais ça serait bien
mal à lui et bonne boule d'or tu vois il
pensez vous que ces pauvres gens
méritent ce qui leur arrive
non non qui êtes-vous que voulez vous
qui êtes vous j'essaie de vous aider qui
ce jeu auquel vous jouez vous comprenez
qu'il ne vous fait pas du bien
il ne fait de bien à personne à les
divertir spécialement francs dans votre
façon de jouer
bardot alors je vous permets pas
monsieur et vous prie pour qu'elle voie
calvitie est là dans votre [ __ ] de
bureaux glauque là mais moi je foutais
fausse moi j'ai grandi avec ma mère
seule
il m'insultait retourne à sa fidèle et
le bureau se dégrade
à vous comporter avec autant de
complaisance oui vous me faites peur je
le provoque oui et croyez-vous que moi
je suis bien rire ouais toi tu es le psy
du mec qui joue un type down vous est
réel c'est le coeur du problème
tout tourne autour de cette question oui
arrive et vous encore à faire la
différence
papa trop je sais pas je pas trop ce que
tu veux j'ai juste été un acteur un peu
connu dans la vraie vie aux caisses bas
il te le donne en mai a pas de problème
ouais mais bon les gens c'est bien dans
cet épisode cadre de huntingdon alors là
autant vous dire que voilà dans
l'épisode d'avant il me semble que je
vais me dis que ça va partir en steaks
dans cet épisode là bas je sais qu'on
l'a fait nous mêmes georges c'est pour
toi vers savoir garder n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo kadhafi
et puis on se retrouve très bientôt pour
un autre épisode portez vous bien tient
tout le monde pis ça vaut j'ai compris
aller aux [ __ ] les doigts c'est moi
j'ai compris allez on y va
allez allez michael était un bonhomme
d'un bonhomme d'un bonhomme t'inquiète
ça va aller tout seul tout seul tout
seul tout seul tout seul seysses
sèchement ouais je sais oui